we have one more piece of news about the
live golf tour some of the golfers
playing are now taking legal action
against the pga tour
they've left the pga and now they're
being told they can never play in it
again fox's bill malugen has been
tracking the developments for us tonight
who joins us now hey bill
hey tucker that's right today 11 members
of the saudi-backed live golf circuit
all filed an anti-trust lawsuit against
the pga tour and they're accusing the
tour of illegally crushing competition
as well as retaliating against players
so the pga tour has suspended golfers
who are lured to live golf through some
significant appearance fees as well as
massive prize funds and the tour has
pointed to its own bylaws that ban
members from taking part in any other
events without the permission of the
commissioner effectively what the tour
is doing is they're banishing tour
players if they decide to take part in
the live golf circuit now phil mickelson
and bryson deshambo are both part of the
lawsuit they are suing the pga tour all
in an effort to challenge their
suspensions and part of that lawsuit
reads in part quote the tour's conduct
serves no purpose other than to harm
players and foreclose the entry of the
first meaningful competitive threat the
tour has faced in decades here's what
liv golfers in the lawsuit had to say
about the tour this past weekend
exclusively to your show
i think it's unfortunate that we
couldn't try to bring this all together
i think everybody would have benefited
i'm not worried about what that tour
does anymore uh you know they've
separated themselves from us everybody's
like i said is against us and has
basically treated us like uh you know
the black cats of the world so pga tour
is saying anyone who participates and
live will be banned for life from pga
yeah it doesn't matter 28 are you
worried about that no no i think it'll
get figured out and then i personally
know that it will get figured out
whether it's legally or whether they
come to the table and work out terms i
definitely think it'll it'll all wash
itself out in the future
pretty shortly
and tucker live golf and the mountain of
money behind it has really sent the
sport into some pretty tumultuous times
live golf is offering 25 million dollars
in prize money at its tournaments that's
a heck of a lot more than the pga tour
currently offers and top pros are also
being offered hundreds of millions of
dollars as sign up bonuses that's
obviously a hard offer to not at least
consider the pga tour may soon be forced
to work with live golf though as the
justice department is also investigating
the pga tour over potential anti-trust
violations as well so the tension
continues to increase we'll send it back
to you
don't listen for us thank you so much
thanks
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight